president biden embarking on his big
midterm blitz to november the
commander-in-chief out in ohio today
giving a speech after revving up the
base last night in d at the dnc and
that's where he doubled down on his
omega-republican attacks but seemed like
he wants to have it both ways
not every republican is a mag of
republican not every republican embraces
the extreme ideology i know because i've
worked with them in the mainstream
republicans and there are still a few of
them left
but the extreme set of maggie
republicans
has chosen to go backwards full of anger
violence hate and division and that's
what their game is
and together
democrats independents and mainstream
republicans can choose a different path
extreme maggie republicans just don't
threaten our personal and economic
rights
they embrace political violence
democrats offer a vision for a better
america it's within the reach our reach
the president isn't the only source of
gop fear mongering a new york times
article joining the bandwagon claiming a
narrow hard right gop house majority
could spell chaos sean we must go to you
to see about this um would you where
would you fall in the continuum of ultra
omega to mega well i
there's no ultra mega there's just mega
right people want to make america great
again it's an american first policy as
opposed to globalism we want to put our
people our country first and we when
biden's talking about extreme ideology
you can't help a look at the democrat
party today and say listen they're
attacking the second amendment they're
attacking the first amendment in freedom
of speech with they have open borders
they're uh they're trying to transition
kids sterilize you know kids under 18.
um they're advocates of partial birth
abortion they're promoting socialism
those are the extreme sides of the
democrat party where if you look at
republicans they're again talking about
the issues that they've talked about
since the 1980s lower taxes
less regulation a secure border a strong
military but to to a question on this i
don't think this is going to work with
the american people
um you got to win the middle and when
you go so hard against donald trump and
his supporters i think a lot of people
in the middle don't like that and just
one last point this he's going so hard
on donald trump i think it really brings
to light what's happened with regard to
mar-a-lago this was a political attack
the raid at mar-a-lago was a political
attack because joe biden sees donald
trump and his supporters a threat to his
his power and using the fbi and the doj
to go after mar-a-lago is all about
politics not about documents what do you
think about the strategy jessica like
they must have done some sort of focus
grouping that said this is going to work
for them and they don't they don't think
that they have to win all the
independence they just have to win a
certain number to keep to hold on by
their fingernails is that the idea
i think we'd like more than just our
fingernails but yeah i mean everyone's
just trying to win whatever coalition is
going to work for them we don't we're so
polarized we're not going to have
overwhelming majorities people are
partisans generally and even
independents when you look at it about
40 of americans identify as independent
but nearly 100 of them lean one way or
the other and especially with an issue
like abortion on the ballot and it'll be
on the ballot like in kansas in places
like michigan now um but everyone knows
what it means if we get another
conservative supreme court justice
versus you know we can get a liberal one
um people have their corners in terms of
the strategy though i thought it was
interesting reuters has a no a new poll
out that says 58 of americans think that
the make america great again movement is
threatening our democratic foundations
and that includes 25 percent of
republicans so if you look at the
numbers of republicans that joe biden
needs to pick off 25 percent would be
just fine you can win like that with all
of your democrats and with independence
the left-leaning ones and a lot of the
right-leaning ones who do not see the
world like you do sean who don't think
that we're it's not napoleon is that a
real sean b a serious person here don't
just say if you don't like something it
is not fake news polls are real i've
done polling in my life and some of the
polls actually post labor day judge
you know we sort of started the week
with thinking wow biden's got some wind
at his back and then now the polls are
starting to come out post labor day and
you see somebody like herschel walker in
georgia now
moving up brian kemp moving up and
you're seeing a little bit more of this
tightening as we all suggested post
labor day you would see right right it
is tightening there's no question about
it but you know one of the things that
concerns me about this mag some of the
maggots are not everybody's a bad mega
first of all name me one mega other than
donald trump okay give me the name of
someone doug
no i'm not asking you i'm asking the
president who is he identifying as the
others that we should all hate because
they're going to destroy democracy i
mean we can't ignore what's really in
front of us and that is that there's a
president who's trying to get us to hate
the others and that is not american this
is a president who promised to unify all
of us and he's done just the opposite
he's dividing us he's not defining it
he's not saying who he's talking about i
can work with some i can't work with
others because the pushback was so great
you're calling everyone in who's a
republican a dirt bag is that what it's
coming down but
no wait a minute the the truth is that
it's the democrats who are offering the
giveaways they're offering the handouts
and the government aid and they want to
give the the phones and everything else
the republicans are saying you know we
stand for some kind of you know uh a
financial conservative focus as opposed
to paying off student loans and on and
on i mean the thing that bothers me is
not so much is it getting closer isn't
getting close who is he talking about
why is he dividing america he should
lose because of that one of the things
that the president said today was that
anyone who had talked about cutting
entitlements would be a mega republican
that's been a policy for republicans for
a long time
in a sustainable way that nobody gets
their social security cut
so the reason why that poll is is
showing this is showing that fear is
effective right and and that's what this
is about they're creating fear of this
kind of like phantom mega terror group
the republicans can't let this succeed
because this again is another example of
joe's pretend moderation right and this
isn't america's fault joe's really good
at playing middle of the road and the
media happily promotes the ruse it's
basically it's pure bait and switch it
happened before and after with the
election it's like being told you're
gonna swim against a biological female
and it turns out it's leah thomas you
know he's the leah thomas of presidents
now he claims now he claims that he's
the law and order guy and why because he
condemns january 6th that's what they're
working from so far it's kind of worked
but we'll there's a problem with this
the old coot we condemned all of us
condemned january 6 we also condemn the
riots the year and a half of riots the
explosion in crime we condemn that every
day the daily degradations we see on
their streets we condemn that constantly
you never have condemned those things
you hid during a lot of this stuff so if
you're a law and order guy then so is
jesse smallett and that's what the
republicans have to come back with
with some tough language of their own
exactamundo little lady okay coming up
sanctuary city mayors not offering
sanctuary to the migrants being bust
their towns we'll tell you all about it
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now